government funding cuts are putting some
of the world's most vulnerable people at
risk of hunger and malnutrition the
United Nations world food program issued
a strong warning recently saying that an
additional 24 million people could slip
into emergency hunger in the next year a
50 increase from the current level so
far the organization has received less
than half of the 25 billion it says it
needs to prevent starvation and
operations have been slashed in places
like Afghanistan Somalia Syria and the
Democratic Republic of Congo earlier
this year conflict Force collude care to
flee Sudan now she's trying to get help
for people in her home country I don't
think there's a proper recognition of
just how severe things are in Sudan and
just how urgent the needs are there is
an over emphasis on the Ukrainian
conflict to detriment of other conflicts
and often what that means is that
funding envelopes that are made
available for Ukraine are not utilize in
the same way to for other countries
including Sudan members of the U.N
security Council recently met to discuss
the problem and are calling on the
private sector to do more this moment
calls for bold action it calls for
breaking out of our business as usual
model
it calls for thinking holistically about
how we address increasingly protest
protracted crises and it calls for
everyone ending poverty and hunger are
supposed to be the United Nations top
priorities under the sustainable
development goals but the trends are all
moving in the wrong direction
humanitarians blame conflict climate
change and the enduring impacts of the
covid pandemic
there are more than 340 million people
worldwide facing acute food insecurity
some 40 million of them are already at
emergency levels of hunger that's in
this magnitude have consequences
and those consequences are not just for
people
who may lose their lives or their
livelihoods this is the first time in
the organization's 60-year history that
had seen such significant shortfalls the
worry now is that more hungry people
will only lead to more Global
instability Kristen salumi Al Jazeera
the United Nations
now Khan Ross is founder of the
non-profit Advisory Group independent
Diplomat joins us by Skype from the
ganway in the United Kingdom good to
have you with us sir so first of all how
can funding be raised in a cash-strapped
post-covered world
that's a very good question with the
cost of living crisis across the world
and affecting places like the United
States and the European Union I don't
see much Prospect for extra cash being
raised for sustainable development
climate transition or anything else I
think the money can only be raised by
mobilizing private sector funds the
enormous amount of savings and
investment funds that dwell in the
global North we need to find a way of
Shifting that money to the global South
for development and the climate
transition
if communities are increasingly becoming
hungry what does that mean for the world
more political instability more crime
more migration
I I'm willing to attribute particular
phenomena to you know the terrible
phenomena of poverty and hunger but
certainly one consequence will surely be
an increase in migration the world is
facing a rapid increase in the amount of
migration last year the High
Commissioner for refugees of the UN said
there were about 110 million refugees of
whom about 60 million were climate
refugees fleeing from places where the
environment has become unbearable that
number will only increase and surely
hunger and poverty will only increase a
good example is the number of people
fleeing Venezuela which is in a
disastrous economic condition there is
real hunger and people are fleeing North
in vast numbers
there have been calls that the United
Nations security Council for the private
sector to do more to fill this Gap
whereas countries cut back on their
budgets what do you make of that
argument
I don't love the argument because I
think governments themselves should have
done more there should be more Global
Leadership to reach out and help the the
poorer parts of the world to develop and
to make the climate transition to
renewable energy but I don't see that
happening politically and in the absence
of government action I do think we had
to turn to the private sector and look
at how to so-called de-risk investments
in the private sector in the developing
world but also de-risk investment in the
renewable energy transition which needs
to happen on a global scale
all right thank you so much for sharing
your thoughts
you're welcome thank you for having me